yeah welcome to yet another blitz game
five minutes on icc playing a foam
cutter sicilian well i'm not a regular
you fall play up some always interesting
to see what happens yeah i don't i don't
really want especially cough or
something like that play Bishop to b5
yeah be takes c6 and some leading to
different position 10 then d take c60
takes c6 or some a bit more common and
the only thing I know is that I should
go for C 3 d 4 against the B takes c6
set up I know it helps black to get rid
of the the double bond but it also gives
wider a good center and ideas against
the c6 pawn yeah for example right now I
could consider Queen a form I'm not sure
Bishop g4 looks som like it's somewhat
somewhat strange move to me like you I
would get the bishop a hour just to win
your temple at some point
yeah I could to make it play this this
tech i'm on the seaport we need for not
sure if taking on f3 SL it's a big deal
okay well maybe just play and play it
simple this 92 so that i can recapture
with the the night under the right
circumstance and now quickly get on the
c6 pawn this was my idea with 922 maybe
this is so i think normally nite nite
see three years plate and the structure
from what i know but i'm a friend of
mine from a teammate he used to play out
this way as blackened I know they
usually played them with 93 ya b3 now
yeah probably securing the the queenside
to now hu was hanging so however can
even play Roxy to I want to double up
her on the C file anyway later ok so now
let's get rid of this bishop or you can
get rid of the pin ok he gives me the
Sun to ship surprisingly I thought
Bishop d7
certainly don't mind to on to not play
against the bishop anymore the bishops
weren't so dangerous but still I was
more expecting a retreat there maybe
this was through the idea preparing c5
and this in this way on c5 um maybe he's
got 95 and no this is possible okay yeah
anyway I need to take I thought that
maybe 95 was an idea maybe it's just
nonsense but it certainly am what sells
something to to consider ok so in
destruction now he's got a very good
Bishop on g7 which might go to deform
being secured by the on by the sea pawn
and then I've got this weakness some
that I can play against on c5 the
question is how do I position the pieces
i would like I'm the knight on f3 so
that this Bishop is detect immediately
not sure about night c4 I mean it'sit's
looked looking a nice on c4 but it
doesn't attack anything I want to really
go to f3 and pawn to e5 would be nice
positionally but it's covered
unfortunately
not sure how to how to play that it
looks like a strange square for the
Queen ready but I want to go to f3 and I
didn't see another square I mean g3 am
but it's it's it's it's um also looking
weird okay so I got to f3 yeah no I'm
threatening i think ii five cutting off
the bishop it maybe gives him the d5
square so ma'am not sure if it's really
a threat but still it looks like and
that the night is correct on on f3 it
should play quickly gaining a bit of
time if I've instantly also was an idea
but I'm not sure yet if this is really
great he cannot play a bishop before I
think when he can but it's not I bh6 sa
you know so he cannot even cannot even
consider this so if I've now should I
wait let's let's go for this e 6 also
also possibility really weakening his
his structure oh he's six interesting so
should i transfer the night to see for
now let's say let's do this it's very
secure on c4 and it's got this idea of
96 coming I win a temple were on the
Queen and then I can also play rookie to
and and secure the poem
yeah not sure if i played this the best
possible way maybe it it wasn't wasn't
so great gather c5 fools yeah it looks
nice but it gives it gives black this d
farm yeah should I take a five good
question rookie five maybe I still
really needed to do that now I've got 96
as a possibility lalaloopsy five
complicated I take nights maybe knight
c6 now it's in a lot of and some in some
Forks and c5 is hanging of course my
bone structure is a rag but it's 2-2
past poles
this is annoying just take him okay so
now maybe use them use the a poem now
should it should be fine for white but
hi morning so still not completely easy
camp also equal but I've got there I've
got the better pawns somehow I managed
very frigid with what the two what's
happening with the time yet yeah okay
now he's got the the age porn but I was
just looking at the clock waiting for
him to to to to lose on time and maybe
this is a good now for black hair with
the age porn possible it was certainly a
winning around here I think with the
yeah computer gives plus free yeah with
the bonds here ruin gabardelli I think i
misplayed this and around yet it should
be somewhat better for white but um
maybe a 95 computer gives 95 in this
position this looks like a good idea
just attacking f7 and how do you protect
us maybe rookie afraid you me to play
yeah it's much better than what I played
I think this is really a mistake I was
having some doubts during the game but
it's difficult with a little time this
simply helps them to play rook g5 rook
da to get get something on the D farm
and him
this is already tricky yeah it looks
nice on c4 this night but he's got the
default and open fire counts for
something yeah played this badly Vic
lucky that he got lost in the tactics
and term lost some time at the end yeah
thanks for watching